lady gaga shows fans what it's like to
live with chronic pain in a new
documentary paranoia fair body pains
aiya tea on Sunday the singer announced
that she was postponing the European leg
of her Johanne world tour due to her
fibromyalgia condition now new trailer
for her upcoming Netflix documentary
Gaga 5 foot 2 offers a glimpse into her
health struggles I have chased this for
five years
Gaga credits her little monsters for
helping her deal with the discomfort but
when I feel the adrenaline and my fans
the 31 year old also details her chronic
pain in an Instagram post on Monday
apologizing for postponing her tour
quote I will tell my story in more depth
and plan to take this on strongly so I
can not only raise awareness but expand
research for others who suffer as I do
et caught up with Gaga at the
documentaries premiere at the Toronto
International Film Festival where she
opened up about how the movie will show
fans she's just like anyone else at the
end of the day I'm my father's daughter
I'm my mother's daughter and my sister's
sister
[Music]
you
[Music]